that's a real pleasure to let you know
about a special activity that we're just
about to launch the fast festival
festival of art science and technology
is a core part of MIT 150th anniversary
and it's really wonderful that this
fantastic innovative arts festival is
such a major part of MIT celebration we
all know that MIT is famous for its
innovations and science and engineering
but the arts are actually the special
ingredient at MIT the thing that makes
the culture innovative and special and
creative and we want to tell that story
so in typical MIT fashion we've invented
a festival which is quite unusual
instead of lasting for a compact two
weeks it lasts for three months and
instead of taking place in a performing
arts facility in one part of campus
little by little it will animate the
entire campus so the fast festival is
structured in a series of clustered
intensive weekends that extend from
early February February 3rd 4th and 5th
through May 7th the first weekend
combines mi t--'s great tradition of
Visual Arts with a retrospective of Stan
Van Der Beek a look at MIT x' tradition
of visual arts modernism and technology
and a really exciting day and evening on
the tradition of music and technology at
MIT all the way back to the very first
computers that made music to the newest
robotic music instruments in the
beginning of March we have a day March
5th which is devoted to music and
language how they're similar and how
they might be different talking about
that and also presenting quite a
wonderful concert featuring a range of
mi t--'s amazing composers and also a
look at the arts and neuroscience what
is it in our minds that makes us respond
to visual stimuli in different ways and
how can artistic expression actually
change the way our minds work in the
middle of March you'll have a chance to
see my opera if you want to it's called
death and the powers
it's an unusual robotic opera that was
premiered in Monaco in the middle of
April we have a very exciting series of
events which we're calling fast future
starts with a marathon music concert
on Friday April 15th which brings
together two of the most famous
contemporary music ensembles in the
world the Kronos Quartet and bang on a
can and the final weekend which really
really will be unusual is called fast
light with a big event on Saturday May
7th what we've done is to contact
faculty and students from all around the
Institute and challenge them to look at
the physical infrastructure of the
campus to imagine how to enhance it so
that we can enjoy what's already there
and to put things in the campus which
allow us to experience things which we
wouldn't otherwise one idea is to make
the waterfront which often is a kind of
backdoor to MIT come alive as a face to
Boston and as a new welcoming portal to
MIT we're doing this with a combination
of installations but especially with
light light everywhere light on
buildings light in the river light along
the bridges and railings be very very
spectacular and throughout the campus in
interior spaces you'll find a really
unusual array of experiences spaces to
explore and additions to the MIT
environment which will totally transform
it and one of the culminating events of
the May seventh fast light is showing a
historically important and quite
remarkable inflatable by the great
artist Otto Pina who for many years was
director of the Center for Advanced
visual studies at MIT it's a spectacular
piece of sculpture that will be inflated
and floated and supported by a large
group of the MIT community who are being
trained over the spring spring time to
show this work it's the first time this
will have been shown it goes up right in
Killian Court which is the spectacular
centerpiece of MIT facing the river and
we think it will bring the entire fast
festival to a focal point and mostly
we'd like you to come and see this
you've got a lot of time it's over three
months unlike any other festival that
you will likely have seen whatever ideas
you have about MIT we think this will
let you see this fantastic innovative
creative culture
which has no boundaries between
disciplines in a really new light and we
hope you come and join us
you